we are going to hear from some of you
today
we are going to uh speak to people via
the david pakman show
discord which is it's the hot new thing
to quote the former guy you can find it
at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go to
billy from california billy from
california you're on the air
david yes
listen the new york state attorney
general has announced that they're going
to start investigating
the trump organization not just a civil
capacity but in a criminal capacity
that's right we covered it so there's
basically two things going on
the sci vance investigation was criminal
all along
the leticia james investigation was
civil
it is now criminal you are 100 correct
my friend
sure and my question is when are you
gonna start pandering to your audience a
little bit
and this spell with this fiction that
donald trump is never gonna get arrested
and the united states doesn't arrest
presidents
i i i still believe that i mean listen i
don't pander
one way or the other what i say on this
program is what i believe
i you know they're investigating the
trump organization
um criminally i think that if it reaches
trump
it will be civil and i think if it if
the criminal charges would be against
people
other than trump and even if trump is
charged i think there's no perp walk i
think there's no jail time
david do you think people listen to ben
shapiro because they think his takes are
interesting
they only listen to him because he tells
them what they want to hear you gotta
patronize us a little bit
tell us exactly how the perp walks gonna
go down
right exactly the jumpsuit the cell
the view i want to hear it all but then
what happens
is when it never happens when it never
happens then people call in and say
david why were you saying trump was
going to get arrested and i'd have to be
like you know
i never really believed it i did it for
billy in california
that's fine that's fine then i look
stupid then i look even stupider than i
normally look
well it's a hard bar to uh
leave it at that anyways thanks david i
appreciate your honest takes actually
um and we're not giving us any sense of
falsehood but
i am still hopeful that at some point
justice is going to be served
yes i mean we all remain in a prison
cell but
i would love to see trump perp walked in
handcuffs believe me
i would love it i just would be lying if
i told you i think it's going to happen
i do yeah yeah all right my friend billy
from california very important topic i
appreciate it